well we like war we like war we're a
warlike people we like war because we're
good at it you know why we're good at it
because we get a lot of practice this
country's only 200 years old and already
we've had 10 major Wars we average a
major war every 20 years in this country
so we're good at it and it's a good
thing we are we're not very good at
anything else anymore can't build a
decent car can't make a TV set or a VCR
where the [ __ ] got no steel industry
left can't educate our young people
can't get health care to our old people
but we can bomb the [ __ ] out of your
country all right
[Applause]
especially if your country is full of
brown people oh we like that don't we
that's our hobby that's our new job in
the world bombing ground people Iraq
Panama Grenada Libya you got some brown
people in your country tell them to
watch the [ __ ] out or we'll goddamn bomb
them who when's the last white people
you can remember that we bombed can you
remember the last white can you remember
any white people we've ever bombed the
Germans those are the only ones and
that's only because they were trying to
cut in on our action they wanted to
dominate the world [ __ ] that's our
[ __ ] job they of how we started think
of that this country was founded by a
group of slave owners who told us all
men are created equal
oh yeah all men except for Indians and
[ __ ] and women right always liked to
use that authentic American language
this was a small group of unelected
white male land holding slave owners who
also suggested their class be the only
one allowed to vote now that is what's
known as being stunningly and
embarrassingly full of [ __ ] and I think
I think Americans really show their
ignorance when they say they want their
politicians to be honest
what are these [ __ ] cretins talking
about if honesty were suddenly
introduced into American life the whole
system would collapse no one would know
what to do
honesty would [ __ ] this country up and I
think deep down Americans know that
that's why they elected and re-elected
Bill Clinton
because because the American people like
their [ __ ] right out front where
they can get a good strong whiff of it
Clinton might be full of [ __ ] but at
least he lets you know it dole tried to
hide it didn't eat dole kept saying I'm
a plain and honest man [ __ ] people
don't believe that
what did Clinton say he said hi folks
I'm completely full of [ __ ] and how do
you like that and the people said you
know something at least he's honest at
least he's honest about being completely
full of [ __ ]
there's a reason education sucks it's
the same reason that it will never ever
ever be fixed it's never going to get
any better don't look for it be happy
with what you got because the owners of
this country don't want that I'm talking
about the real owners now the real
owners the big wealthy business
interests that control things and make
all the important decisions to get the
politicians the politicians are put
there to give you the idea that you have
freedom of choice you don't you have no
choice you have owners they own you they
own everything
they own all the important land they own
and control the corporations they've
long since bought and paid for the
Senate the Congress the state houses the
city halls they got the judges in their
back pockets and they own all the big
media companies so they control just
about all of the news and information
you get to hear they got you by the
balls they spend billions of dollars
every year lobbying lobbying to get what
they want well we know what they want
they want more for themselves and less
for everybody else but I'll tell you
what they don't want they don't want a
population of citizens capable of
critical thinking they don't want well
informed well educated people capable of
critical thinking they're not interested
in that that doesn't help them that's
against their
that's right I got this real [ __ ] thing
I do it's called thinking and I'm not a
very good American because I like to
form my own opinions
I don't just roll over when I'm told to
sad to say most Americans just roll over
on command not me I have certain rules I
live by my first rule I don't believe
anything the government tells me nothing
[Applause]
then you have the media not just the
news media let's include them all the
media are almost literally exploding
with [ __ ] because they're located
right at the crossroads of all the other
[ __ ] the media are made up of equal
parts advertising politics business
public relations and show business these
people are sitting right at [ __ ]
junction there's enough [ __ ] in the
media for Texas to open a branch office
and you still have enough left over to
start two law firms in a Christian
bookstore
[Music]
this whole country has a manhood problem
big manhood problem in the USA you can
tell from the language we use language
always gives you away what did we do
wrong in Vietnam we pulled out not a
very manly thing to do is it when you
are [ __ ] people you got to stay in
there and [ __ ] them good [ __ ] stay in
there and keep [ __ ] them until
they're all dead we left a few women and
children alive in Vietnam and we haven't
felt good about ourselves since that's
why in the Persian Gulf George Bush had
to say this will not be another Vietnam
he actually used these words he said
this time we're going all the way
imagine an American president using the
sexual slang of a 13 year old to
describe his foreign policy if you want
to know what happened in the Persian
Gulf just remember the names of the two
men who were running that war Dick
Cheney and colon Powell somebody got
[ __ ] in the air
[Applause]
you know if I had to say to you what is
the answer I would say massive bloodshed
I really would
I don't really honestly deep down
believe in political action I think the
system contracts and expands as it wants
to it accommodates these changes I think
the civil rights movement was an
accommodation on the part of the those
who own the country I think they see
where their self-interest lies they see
a certain amount of freedom seems good
an illusion of Liberty give these people
give these people a voting day every
year so that they'll have the illusion
of meaningless choice meaningless choice
that we go like slaves and say Joe I've
voted the limits of debate in this
country are are are established before
the debate even begins and everyone else
is marginalized they're made to seem
either to be communist or was some sort
of disloyal person a kook there's a word
and now it's conspiracy say they've made
that something that that is that it
should not be even entertained for a
minute that powerful people might get
together and have a plan doesn't happen
you're a kook you're a conspiracy buff
so who cure that death bloodshed I don't
advocate it but I see that it's really
the only